good morning or good evenin what
happened my name is Paolo Dall'Oglio and
I'm a monk in the desert of Syria and
very very bad english although wish to
speak havoc in the next video will be
Narvik yes the Rome mold are important
model role model are important for our
region and our society and those moguls
when you say model should be from the
ethical point of view on the Attic point
of view from the model of you something
really really not only hasten at the
level should be convincing to be
coherent and end this one belong we like
a society able to appreciate
transparency we are rooted in looking
and seeking the
the relationship was power the power the
father that power power the professor
power of the player the we all over the
world that here power cam before and
after the law and justice and so my role
model means for me deeply to look look
forwards as commenting and for people
that are able to pay I will not say
table the blood they were the passions
paying with a consistency paying with a
faithfulness to the kind of values they
want to embody the life and in their
society we have models in the our
religious I models ideals
people have been able to put spiritual
values before hi and after interests and
this is what is saving Alice's and isn't
it today with the family values the
religious man don't let bill we have
something to build on where but we have
not only to stay attached to it that's
not enough they have to start new life
on that base with a lot of capacity
invention and guilty and and and fantasy
and capacity of change cuz parents
and coherence